Es klingt wie der Sound eines Science-Fiction
Thrillers, doch für die Fachleute der NASA
ist diese historische Messung ein entscheidender
Meilenstein.
Die Rede ist von der faszinierenden Aufnahme,
die der NASA-Sonde “InSight” gelungen
ist.
Denn bei dem “Zittern”, wie die Forschungsteams
es bezeichnen, handelt es sich höchstwahrscheinlich
um ein Erdbeben auf dem Roten Planeten.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Es war der 128.
Tag der Mars-Mission von “InSight”: Am
6.
April hatte das seismische Instrument der
NASA-Sonde das Rauschen aufgezeichnet.
Die Experten der NASA bezeichnen es als “Zittern”
und sind restlos begeistert.
Kein Wunder, denn schließlich handelt es
sich bei diesem “Zittern” aller Wahrscheinlichkeit
nach um die allererste Aufnahme eines Erdbeben
auf dem Mars.
Laut NASA eine historische Messung und somit
ein spektakulärer Erfolg.
Auf solch ein Signal habe man schon seit Monaten
gewartet.
Der Seismograph - “Seismic Experiment for
Interior Structure”, kurz: SEIS - wurde
von der französischen Weltraumbehörde Centre
National d'Études Spatiales (CNES) entwickelt
und befindet sich schon seit Dezember 2018
auf dem Mars.
Das Instrument horcht quasi in den Roten Planeten
hinein, um Erschütterungen zu registrieren
und ist dabei vor den extremen Winden und
Temperaturschwankungen auf dem Roten Planeten
geschützt.
SEIS hatte in den vergangenen Monaten schon
drei Ausschläge messen können.
Die Analyse dieser Messungen dauert noch an.
Doch nach Ansicht der Forschungsteams hatte
es sich dabei höchstwahrscheinlich lediglich
um viel Wind gehandelt.
Doch das sei bei der zuletzt detektierten
Erschütterung etwas anderes.
Dazu der “InSight”-Experte Bruce Banerdt:
“Wir haben bisher Hintergrundgeräusche
gesammelt, doch dieses Ereignis markiert offiziell
den Beginn eines neuen Forschungsfeldes: Der
Erdbebenkunde des Mars!“
Auch wenn noch kein endgültiger Beweis dafür
vorliegt - das NASA-Forschungsteam ist sich
ziemlich sicher, dass das aufgezeichnete Zittern
aus dem Mars-Inneren stammt.
Die veröffentlichte Aufnahme enthält auch
noch andere Geräusche; die die Experten dem
Mars-Wind und dem Roboterarm zuordnen.
Dennoch stellt das detektierte Beben die Experten
vor große Rätsel: Wo liegt sein Ursprung
und wie ist es entstanden?
Schließlich besteht der Mars aus nur einer
einzigen Platte.
Das Beben kann also - anders als die meisten
Erdbeben auf der Erde - nicht durch die Verschiebung
von Kontinentalplatten zustande gekommen sein.
Das erklärt jedoch auch, warum das Mars-Beben
im Vergleich zu einem Beben auf der Erde extrem
schwach ist.
Hier auf der Erde hätten wir es wohl nicht
einmal bemerkt.
Die NASA-Fachleute gehen bislang davon aus,
dass Risse in der Mars-Kruste aufgebrochen
sind und für die Erschütterung gesorgt haben.
Solche Risse entstehen, wenn der Planet abkühlt.
Auch wenn das jetzt gemessene Mars-Beben eher
klein war, und noch wirklich keine soliden
Erkenntnisse über den Aufbau des Planeten
liefert, macht es Hoffnung auf mehr.
Denn die Aufzeichnung belegt, dass das SEIS-Instrument
tatsächlich sensibel genug ist, um selbst
solche schwachen Erschütterungen zu registrieren.
Fachleute hoffen, dass pro Monat etwa ein
Beben mit einer ähnlichen Stärke registriert
werden kann.
Dazu Charles Yana vom SEIS-Team: “Wir sind
begeistert von diesem ersten Erfolg und freuen
uns darauf, weitere solche Messungen in den
kommenden Jahren zu bekommen”.
Und damit könnten wir endlich den Aufbau
und die Vorgänge im Inneren des Roten Planeten
verstehen.
Denn die Ausbreitung der seismischen Wellen
lässt Rückschlüsse über die Materialien
zu, aus denen Kruste, Mantel und Kern bestehen.
Übrigens gelang es der NASA vor fast fünf
Jahrzehnten, mit genau dieser Technik den
Aufbau des Mondes zu verstehen.
Durch die Analyse einiger tausend Beben auf
dem Mond im Zeitraum zwischen 1969 und 1972
konnten Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
nämlich die einzelnen Schichten des Mondes
ermitteln.
Sind Erde und Mond dasselbe?
Anklicken, anschauen und natürlich Neugierzone
abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!